basketball it was a team sport it wasn't
a one-on-one game
and y'all seen the comedy sketch that
was a distortion of what took place
prince is how tall though i mean france
is about the same highest cat wing
right he said about four french used to
play varsity basketball for
high school really yeah and and we all
seen what nate robertson did yeah
at the all-star game so you can't just
look at the dude and go because he's
five foot even
he can't jump or play basketball but
isn't it humiliating in a way i
played basketball against nils lofgren
you know nils from the east street band
bruce springsteen right
right he's he got to be four foot five
he beat the [ __ ] out of me and
basketball is very embarrassing
man never judge a book by its cover what
a person looks like has nothing to do
with what they're capable of so you're
saying that prince like nathan robinson
athlete do you remember you have to go
in any of these concerts
sure speaking we used to jump up some
speakers
that was like almost 20 feet with pumps
on you don't tell me you didn't see that
now i anybody in here i'll challenge you
put some pumps on
and just jump off this desk right here
and see if you're gonna break your eggs
i am a big